“MILLIONAIRES”:
A few weeks ago,
I made a video about big tech as I tend to do
and somewhere in the video I mentioned that FAANG
engineers generally have enough money to retire
by the time they’re in their 30s. After all,
they tend to cross the $200,000 salary mark pretty
early in their career and by the time they’ve
been in the workforce for 10 years, their initial
stock compensation itself has grown 5 to 10X. So,
it doesn’t take them long to become a millionaire
or even a multi millionaire. To this, an Apple
engineer commented that retiring by 30 was the
funniest line in the video. He went on to claim
that he had been working at Apple for almost 10
years now and that he was nowhere near retirement.
We had a bit of back and forth after this but
he eventually said this. “I'm not a manager.
But I'm in the highest tier of Software Engineer.
Just to give you a sense of my total compensation,
I pay six figures in federal taxes per year.
(And I still have to pay California tax on top
of that.) I'm a multi-millionnaire. I own a house.
I own more than 1 million worth of US$ of Apple
stocks. But here is the thing. It doesn't make
me rich in Silicon Valley. I'm still very middle
class. The cost of life is so high.” It might be
easy to look at this and be like: Oh, it’s just
another multi millionaire complaining about how
they don’t have enough money but I think there’s
a lot more layers to this. For one, I think this
engineer is very much genuine in that he doesn’t
feel comfortable retiring in California even
with a multi million dollar net worth. Moreover,
statistically speaking, being a milllioniare
really isn’t all that special nowadays. In fact,
having a million dollar net worth somehow
doesn’t even get you into the top 10% of
households within America and that was as of
2020. Stocks have gone insane since then and
given that the wealthiest 10% of Americans own
89% of the market, they made a killing. So,
being a millionaire may only put you within
the top 20% of Americans. In other words,
nearly ⅕ Americans are from a million dollar
household. So, join me as we take a look at the
history of being a milllioniare and why modern
day millionaires just don’t feel the same.
THE BIRTH OF MILLIONAIRES:
Being a millionaire probably seems
like a super American capitalist ideology but
the term actually dates back to the early 1700s
to France though it did involve America. France
was in a pretty sticky financial situation at the
time as the probability of bankruptcy was becoming
larger and larger with each passing day. Instead
of just cutting back on spending though, the Duke
of Orleans decided that it would be a great idea
to embrace a more modern solution: aka take on a
bunch of debt. Essentially, they would open a sort
of national bank and transfer all of the country’s
debt to the bank. And to pay back this debt,
France was going to open up the Mississippi Valley
for trade and mining. On paper, this was a solid
plan as the Mississippi Valley was not only in
a prime location but it was apparently mineral
rich. Not wanting to miss out, the French would
begin buying shares of the Mississippi Company
like there was no tomorrow, sending the stock
soaring from 500 livres to 18,000 livres. As such,
many of these investors would become extremely
rich on paper leading to the coining of the
term "millionaire" in reference to people having
millions of livres. Unfortunately though, this
high didn’t last that long as the Mississippi
Company’s profits never materialized and the stock
would collapse soon after. Since then, we saw some
references to the world millionaire here and there
from people like Thomas Jefferson but the modern
capitalist millionaire didn’t pop up till the late
1800s during the gilded age. The gilded age was
one of the most prosperous times in US history,
atleast for the rich. In fact, the rich
were wealthier than ever, far wealthier
than even the top billionaires today. These
industrialists owned massive oil companies,
steel companies, banks, and automotive companies.
And these businesses were so dominant that they
often controlled over 90% of their respective
industries. The owners of these mega monopolies
were referred to as millionaires but they weren’t
really millionaires. They weren’t really even
billionaires. Their wealth was best described in
the trillions. They controlled several percentage
points of the entire American GDP which translates
to each of them boasting net worths of a quarter
trillion or a half a trillion. So, originally,
the term millionaire wasn’t used to describe
people with a million dollars per se. Rather, it
was used to describe the Elon Musks and Jeff Bezos
of the world. But the significance of the world
millionaire has only gone downhill since then.
It’s easy to just point at inflation and say that
that’s what devalued millionaires but that’s not
really the case. A million 1880 dollars is only
worth $30 million today, not hundreds of billions.
So, the culprit isn’t inflation. Rather, the real
culprit is actually economic growth. Back in the
late 1800s, the US didn’t measure GDP but it’s
estimated to be somewhere between $10 and $20
billion. Today, the American GDP stands at $26.5
trillion or 1000 to 2000 times more. So, really,
whenever you see the word millionaire back in the
late 1800s and early 1900s, you can just replace
it with the world billionaire because that’s
really what being a millionaire originally was.
THE GOLDEN PERIOD:
Clearly, becoming a millionaire was completely
unreasonable for the average person during the
gilded age and this only became worse during
the great depression but things would bounce back
stronger than anyone thought possible after World
War 2. The 1960s brought with it likely the
strongest economic period in US history from
the average person’s perspective. Unemployment
was consistently in the 3 to 5% range and this
is when the idea of the American dream really
started to flourish. People could come to America,
start a business, and become a millionaire not by
the age of 25 or something but maybe throughout
an entire lifetime. This was also likely the
best time to aim to become a millionaire. It
wasn’t super out there like trying to become a
billionaire or something. But it also wasn’t super
common like the average price of a Californian
house nowadays. It was akin to trying to make
around $10 million today which sounds about
right. A hard and ambitious goal for sure but
also not too out there. But this golden age
of millionaires didn’t last forever. In fact,
it didn’t even last 10 years as the 1970s brought
with it an extraordinary amount of pain. Right
at the beginning of the decade, President Richard
Nixon would put an end to the Bretton Woods System
aka the Gold Standard. This meant that US dollars
would no longer be backed by gold which led much
of the general public losing trust in the dollar.
And as trust plummeted, inflation skyrocketed
and this was much worse than what we saw over the
past few years. Back in the 1970s, inflation would
peak above 10% on two separate occasions. To make
things worse, the Middle Eastern Countries would
ban together and launch an oil strike against
America leading to one of the worst energy crises
of all time. To put things in perspective, within
just these 10 years, the value of the dollar
would over halve while the median price of a home
nearly tripled. Things were getting pretty bad and
American was in desperate need of a change: enter
Ronald Reagan. The landmark of Reagan’s presidency
was no doubt Reagonomics. Now, you can get into
weeds of all of the specifics and intracices but
in a broad sense, Reagonomics was pretty simple.
Essentially, the idea was to make it easier for
rich people to grow their wealth by cutting taxes
and decreasing regulation. As the rich got richer,
some of their wealth should naturally trickle
down to people of all classes or atleast that
was the theory. In practice, this turned out to
be completely false. On one hand, this definitely
reignited the American dream. It’s obviously a lot
easier to make a million dollars when you have to
pay less in taxes and deal with less regulation.
So, the rich did indeed get richer pulling along
the American economy with them. The problem though
was that not much wealth actually made it’s way to
the average American as the rich naturally just
tended to keep the extra money they made. If a
business made an extra $100 in profit, $90 would
just go straight to the owner and maybe $10 would
make it’s way back to the people. Combine this
with the fact that Reagan had to cut down on a
bunch of social programs to make this work and
suddenly the average person was worse off than
before. But there was a select group of average
people that were doing better than ever before.
TECH MILLIONAIRES:
It may seem like tech bros making
millions is a new phenomenon thanks to companies
like Google, Facebook, and Apple. But, this trend
can actually be traced back to the 1990s. Take
Dell for example. Following Dell’s IPO in 1988,
a whopping 2,700 millionaires would be minted over
the next 20 years. In fact, Dell millionaires were
so common that people just referred to them as
dellionaires and this marked the first step of
the normalization of millionaires. While 2,700
millionaires was definitely a massive amount
for a single company back in the 90s and
2000s, compared to the overall population,
it was still an extremely small amount. But,
this was just the beginning. Keep in mind,
many of the tech companies that dominate the
Fortune 500 today were yet to even be created.
Over the next 20 years, these companies would
grow to unimaginable scales reaching hundreds
of billions if not trillions in market cap.
And I know we talk about such numbers all the
time but let’s take a second to recognize just how
massive a trillion dollars is. A trillion dollars
is literally a million millions. In other words, a
trillion dollar company can make a million people
millionaires. Apple with their $3 trillion market
cap can produce 3 million millionaires. Microsoft,
2.7 million millionaires. Google, 1.5
million millionaires, Amazon, 1.3 million
millionaires. Nvidia, 1.1 million millionaires.
And that’s just the top 5 companies. Of course,
none of these companies have actually created
a million millionaires yet, but what they have
done is create hundreds of thousands of employee
and investor millionaires each. Think about this.
8 out of the top 10 richest people in the world
made all of their money in tech. At this point,
you could even classify Warren Buffett as a tech
billionaire given that he owns a $150 billion
worth of Apple stock. And I imagine that this
is the same case with most millionaires as well.
The US currently boasts a total of 22 million
millionaires most of whom made their money in
tech and live in tech cities like San Francisco,
Seattle, and Austin. In San Francisco for example,
you need to almost be a multi millionaire to even
feel financially comfortable. And that’s not my
opinion. Charles Schwab actually conducted a
full on study about this. They found that to
be financially comfortable in San Francisco,
you need a net worth of $1.7 million. To be
considered wealthy, you need a net worth of $4.7
million. So, our friend from the beginning really
wasn’t exaggerating when he said that being
a multi millionaire very much felt like being
in the middle class atleast in a Californian
tech city. But really, it’s only a matter of
time until it becomes the same case for the rest
of America thanks to inflation, economic growth,
and tech’s increasing omnipresense. What started
off as a way to describe the richest people on
the planet has since fallen to be a generic term
to describe the upper middle class atleast within
America and other western countries. Of course,
a million dollars is still an extraordinary
amount of money outside these countries. But,
that’s why millionaires just don’t feel like
millionaires anymore. The new measure of wealth
seems to be earning a million dollar salary.
Check out this video to learn about ChatGPT’s
struggle to payout million dollar salaries.